O
ANYBODY OR IS IT JUST ME?
>> Sean: NO, JOE, IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
IT'S LIKE PETE BEG.
MORE PAIN AT THE PUMP.
MORE BENEFIT FROM MORE PAIN THAT
YOU ESPERANCE.
WHO KNOWS WHAT JOE WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
WHO KNOWS THEY ARE ADOPTING
THESE INSANE POLICIES.
THEY ARE HURTING THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
I DON'T KNOW THE FED CHAIRMAN,
JEROME POWELL, HE CALLED TODAY'S
NEGATIVE GDP REPORT EVEN WORSE
THAN EXPECTED.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD LISTEN TO HIM
ALTHOUGH I DON'T FRANKLY THINK
HE KNOWS WHAT THE HELL HE'S
DOING EITHER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE DIDN'T EXPECT A GOOD
READING BUT THIS ONE WAS EVEN
WORSE THAN EXPECTED I WOULD SAY.
I DON'T TALK ABOUT MY OWN
PERSONAL ESTIMATE OF WHAT THE
TERMINAL RATE WOULD BE.
I WILL WRITE DOWN THAT.
IT'S GOING TO EVOLVE.
IT HAS EVOLVED FOR ALL
PARTICIPANTS.
IT HAS EVOLVED OVER THE COURSE
OF THE YEAR AS WE LEARN HOW
PERSISTENT INFLATION IS GOING TO
BE.
>> Sean: EVERY AMERICAN NEEDS
TO TAKE.
NONE OF THIS IS GOOD BUT AS PER
USUAL JOE BIDEN AND ALL THE
ADVISORS, THEY REFUSE TO TELL
THE TRUTH WHICH AGAIN IS NOTHING
NEW.
JOE WAS IN DENIAL.
REMEMBER ABOUT AFGHANISTAN?
HE LIED.
WHAT A GREAT SUCCESS.
WE STILL HAVE AMERICANS BEHIND
ENEMY LINES.
IT'S NEARLY ONE FULL YEAR.
DAY 348 SINCE HE ABANDONED THEM.
WE HAVE OUR DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY
SAYING THE BORDER IS SECURE.
IT IS ANYTHING BUT SECURE.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
JOE LIED ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
BUILDUP OF RUSSIAN TROOPS AROUND
UKRAINE.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT HE'S GOING TO INVADE.
WRONG AGAIN.
THEY LIED ABOUT THE SUPPLY
CHAIN.
THEY LIED ABOUT NOT BEING WARNED
ABOUT THE BABY FORMULA SHORTAGE.
THEY LIED REPEATEDLY ABOUT THE
CAUSES OF SPIKING GAS PRICES.
THEY CAUSED THE PRICE BIKE
BECAUSE THEY ARTIFICIALLY REDUCE
THE WORLD SUPPLY.
THEY LIED OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
INFLATION IS TRANSITORY.
AND NOW BIDEN AND EVERYONE
AROUND HIM AND THE MEDIA MOB,
THEY ARE ALL LYING ABOUT WHAT
ARE SOME VERY REAL RECESSION BY
DEFINITION, BY THE DEFINITION
THAT THEY THEMSELVES USED TO
YOUR ZERO.
IN FACT, TODAY'S MASSIVE
SPENDING BILL AND TAX HIKE
RUBBER-STAMPED BY JOE MANCHIN
WILL MAKE THIS RECESSION AND ARE
IMPATIENT THAT MUCH WORSE.
YOU CAN'T FIGHT INFLATION BY
PRINTING MONEY AND RAISING
TAXES.
BY THE WAY, YOU KNOW WHO SAID
THAT?
JOE BIDEN.
I'M SORRY, JOE MANCHIN AND
BARACK OBAMA.
WE WILL PLAY IT LATER.
COURSE BIDEN'S CONSTANT STATE OF
DENIAL AND LYING HAS LED TO
SERIOUS BECAUSE ONCE HIS.
AMERICANS HAVE DIED.
WE HAVE OTHERS LEFT AND
ABANDONED IN AFGHANISTAN.
GROWTH IS AT WAR.
FENTANYL IS POURING ACROSS OUR
BORDERS.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING INSIDE THE
U.S. IS AT AN ALL-TIME HIGH.
NOW AMERICANS ARE BEING CRUSHED
BY JOE'S INFLATION.
HIS RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES, AND
A BRAND-NEW RECESSION.
SO IT'S TIME FOR ALL OF THEM TO
STOP SPINNING, STOP LYING, AND
ADMIT TO THE TRUTH.
IF YOU CAN FOR SUBMIT TO THE
TRUTH, IT SHALL SET YOU FREE.
MAYBE IT WILL START -- WILL
START THINKING ABOUT A COURSE
CORRECTION.
BACK TO SECURING OUR BORDER, GO
BACK TO ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
POLICIES.